[Music]
pornography is uh another one of your
interests
in the book
[Laughter]
right here but but it's not i i don't i
don't celebrate porn you know i use it
occasionally that's how i like to look
at it i celebrate it unlike who who's
celebrating
well that's what you'd be surprised a
lot of guys out there just now watching
what i do
yeah yeah no i think you got to be
careful not to enjoy it too much you
never want to you know if you're about
to watch porn and you do any version of
that yeehaw woohoo you know you're too
you're far gone you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah you know i think that i
think when what you proceed watching
porn is you should probably be working
on something else you know maybe you're
at home alone perhaps writing that novel
or that screenplay
and you're just sitting there and you
have that moment where you're like oh
god what am i thinking this isn't going
to work out
yeah i'm an idiot you porn and that's
when that's when you do it
as a quick little uh
what i'm saying is that the only time
you should watch porn is when you're
falling down the pit of self
and the only thing you can do to stop
your fall is grab hold of your own penis
that's when you watch porn
you want to write that down it's in here
that's written
that is written in the deepest crevices
of my brain right now another good time
is when everyone goes to the grocery
store
[Applause]
see
that's only something a man with a
family could say
he has a family and he has to prepare
differently than me right right
i don't think it's a i don't think it's
a great idea to watch too much porn
that's my point
there's so much of it out on the
internet has changed everything it's not
like when we were kids i'll tell you i
tell you you're right i tell you you're
right
i mean i think some computers come with
porn on them now is that possible
that's how they sell them you pop open a
new computer like oh my god there's
people having sex right away yeah boy
apple's really changed since jobs died
[Laughter]
no but like you think about it like when
i was 14 13 14 years if there was if
there was a porn that you can get now
like then i mean i would never leave my
room my head would explode i just have a
nub
okay
sorry
wait
my girlfriend she's in the dressing room
you think this is making me look good so
um
no but like you remember when we were
kids you had to know the kid who had an
older brother or the weird dad you know
if you know what i mean you had to keep
look out in front of a bedroom while he
rifled for a mattress through a mattress
or or you had to find like one page of a
porno magazine under a bridge with your
friends
my brother to my brother used to get him
out of dumpsters we would look at porno
that had like potato peels and coffee
grounds on them exactly it was
disgusting but it was fantastic but to
see
yeah but you know that's why you're
aroused by potato peels now
oh yes
yeah i love them but this is like yes it
was a rare this is what it was like in
the depression kids right you'd find
where you'd find a page with your
friends and you'd argue who got to take
it home first and have that moment we're
like oh that's how it works you know and
then like you go back you go back to
that same place like every day for like
a month to see if the rest of the
magazine magically showed up like as if
there were porn trolls out to shrimp
put more filth out for the children
they must learn somewhere
sunrises more bridges yes
[Laughter]
yeah but uh now it's just so you got to
be careful with it because there's a lot
out there it's dangerous you don't want
to get pornhead uh what is pornhead
pornhead you know what pornhead is no i
don't well i can give you the long
version of the short version um
we better do the short version because
this is primarily a show for children
okay
well there's a big analogy but that
would require me saying more than penis
and doing a hand motion that i probably
couldn't do here so
what do you mean that you what have you
done
so far that's allowable so far
now you're censoring yourself
but wait you're like a dirty mime man
you've been
no i didn't do the thing though i didn't
do the the thing
you know the you know
wait can i do it up here and get away
with it
yeah that just means you're yeah i just
meet you
that just means you're you're riding the
subway yeah
it's riding the subway
that's not dirty
or why are you working a ranch and
dinner's ready yeah gear's ready
we gotta get to this clip we gotta get
to this clip